MICHELLE WILLIAMS:
Welcome to the forum,
live streamed worldwide
from the Leadership Studio
at the Harvard T.H. Chan
School of Public Health.
I'm Dean Michelle Williams.
The forum is a collaboration
between the Harvard Chan School
and independent news media.
Each program features
a panel of experts
addressing some of today's most
pressing public health issues.
The forum is one way
the school advances
the frontiers of
public health and makes
scientific insights accessible
to policymakers and the public.
I hope you find this program
engaging and informative.
Thank you for joining us.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINA MARTIN: Thank you, and
welcome so much for joining us.
My name is Tina Martin.
I am an anchor reporter and
host for WGBH news in Boston.
I'm also today's moderator.
Our panelists starting
with my immediate right
are Wanda Barfield.
She is Rear Admiral, US
Public Health Service
and director of the Division
of Productive Health
Services for the
CDC; Ana Langer who
is a professor of the
Practice of Public Health
and director of Women
and Health Initiatives
at Harvard Chan School;
Haywood Brown is the immediate
past president of the American
College of Obstetricians
and Gynecologists;
Susan Mann who is
on the end there
is an obstetrician gynecologist
affiliated with the Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center and
a clinical assistant professor
at Harvard Medical School;
and joining us remotely
is Karen Scott, a
practicing OBGYN leading
the hospital based quality
improvement initiative on birth
equity for and
with black mothers,
birthing people for the
California Maternal Quality
Care Collaborative.
So welcome to you, Karen.
This event is being presented
jointly by PRI's The World
and WGBH, and is part of the
Dr. Lawrence H. and Roberta Cohn
forum series.
And she is here.
Roberta, excuse me.
We are pleased to welcome the
Cohen family and friends here
today.
So welcome to you.
We are streaming
live on websites 4
of the forum and the world.
So please join us there.
We're also streaming live
on Facebook and YouTube,
and the program will
include a brief Q&A.
And we really want to
be sure to get those in,
those questions and answers.
You can email those to us at
the forum at hsph.harvard.edu.
You can also participate in
a live chat that's happening
on the forum site right now.
So let's start off by saying
that millions of babies
are safely delivered in the
United States each year.
Many women will experience
safe and healthy pregnancies
and deliveries and
postpartum periods.
However, we are seeing
a startling trend
in the United States.
At a time when maternal
mortality is dropping
in many places in
the world, death
related pregnancy and
childbirth in the United States
have increased.
And the risk is
triple or quadruple
for black women in America.
Today we're going
to look at what's
driving that national trend
as well as the racial gap,
and then we'll talk about
what we can actually
do about it because it's very
important to actually try
to do something about it.
To set the stage, let's take a
look at a video from ProPublica
which published an
amazing series with NPR
about maternal
mortality in the US.
And it's called Lost Mothers.
Let's take a look.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TINA MARTIN: Wow.
That clip use statistics from
2016 and here we are in 2019.
Those stats are
still distressing
and that clip itself
was disturbing.
Wanda, give us an idea
of the big picture
what's happening here.
WANDA BARFIELD: Well, thank you
for your introduction, Tina,
and thank you for your remarks
about this important issue.
As been mentioned by Tina
and also by the clip,
that we see about 700 women
dying each year in our country
due to pregnancy or
delivery complications.
With better data and
collection techniques
we're getting better
and better in terms
of identifying the causes
of these deaths that
are truly related to
pregnancy as well as delivery.
But while pregnancy
related mortality ratios
have been relatively stable
in the last few years,
we know that overall
pregnancy related
mortality has not decreased.
And this really is
a cause for concern.
And another major
cause for concern
are these evident racial
disparities that we're seeing.
So for more than 30 years we've
seen a disproportionate burden
of death among
African-American women.
Today, black women are
almost four times as
likely to die of a pregnancy
related complication
compared to white women.
And this is really an
unconscionable issue.
Importantly, emerging data from
state based maternal mortality
review committees--
and these are
groups that come together
to try to understand
the causes of death
--they're showing
that 60% of maternal
deaths may be preventable.
And so we have no
reason to believe
that this prevent abilities
that would vary by race.
So we have a lot of
room for opportunities
for intervention in this area.
Better data can also help
us to better understand
the gaps and the drivers
of maternal deaths
and think about ways
that we can prevent them.
So some of what we're seeing
from these review committees
are that there are underlying
chronic conditions that
are disparate particularly
for African-American women.
We're seeing that there are
the effects of unconscious bias
as well as structural racism
that may be contributing
to these deaths.
And then the third issue
is an issue of quality.
We're seeing variation
in hospital quality.
So with a better
data we're going
to get better
understanding of what
we need to do in terms of
quality care initiatives
that may have better impact.
We can also think about
standardized care that
will allow women to get the
right care at the right time
and the right place.
And high quality care is
really an important factor
in trying to improve the care of
women not only in the hospital,
but thinking about care into
the year after delivery.
So we have a real opportunity to
really improve maternal health.
At CDC we're really trying to
see how we can improve data
across the country.
And we have an opportunity
now with the support
through Congress to look at
maternal mortality review
committees.
And so states and
jurisdictions will
have an opportunity to
improve their care for women.
And at this point
I'd like to stop
and I'll give a
chance for Dr. Langer
to further the discussion.
TINA MARTIN: Yes.
Because you study health
trends around the world.
Help us to put this into global
context what's happening here
in the United States.
ANA LANGER: Sure.
Thank you so much
for that question.
Those of us working on
global maternal health
always considered maternal
mortality and severe morbidity
as a problem of low
resource settings.
In fact, after all,
99% of maternal deaths
happen in low and
middle income countries,
but that remaining 1% happens
among vulnerable women
in developed countries.
And in fact the US is a country
where most of those deaths
happen, and probably
the only one, in fact
the only developed country
where the maternal mortality
ratio is going up.
Overall, if you list
the countries from one
with the lowest maternal
mortality ratio, which
is Finland, to the
one with the highest,
the US occupies at
place number 46.
In fact, it's interesting
to see that the US is
below Qatar, Libya,
and of course
all Western European
countries, but Qatar and Libya
are countries with a
much smaller economy
and expenditures in health.
But as Wanda
correctly pointed out,
these deaths don't
happen randomly.
So if you look at
maternal mortality
among non-Hispanic black
women and compare it
with what's happening
in other countries,
you will see that
maternal mortality
among non-Hispanic
black women here
is higher than maternal
mortality in Mexico,
and is the same
one as in Malaysia,
countries you wouldn't think
are doing better than America.
On the other hand, if you
look at maternal mortality
among non-Hispanic
white women, you
will see that the ratio is
above the national ratio
in New Zealand and the UK.
But vary slightly so,
almost at the same level.
At the first report we'll
draw our recent attention
at least to this topic came
mostly from human rights
organizations.
There was this very
important report
from Amnesty International,
and in 2011 it
called deadly delivery,
the maternal health
crisis in the US,
and from journalists,
and you showed that clip from
Nina Martin and ProPublica
and NPR.
But now more
academics, obviously
professional associations,
the CDC and so many
others are doing more studies
and publishing more papers,
academic papers on this issue
trying to understand what's
behind the numbers
and trying to come up
with solutions for the crisis
that we are now facing.
So the drivers, as Wanda
already pointed out,
include lack of
access, poor quality,
and in fact a basic societal
undervaluing of women of color
that we are also trying
to understand better
the reasons for everything
that comes with it.
So the US I think can
learn from other countries.
We've been quite successful in
making maternal mortality come
down in many other places.
So I look forward to maybe
giving some examples later
about that.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
Haywood, during your
time as president
of ACOG you advocated
for policy change that
can improve the state
of maternity care
in the United States.
Tell us a little bit
more about that work.
And listening to you
earlier, we talked
about social determinants
of health and hearing Ana
saying undervaluing women of
color or patients of color.
So what is your
perspective on that?
HAYWOOD BROWN:
Well, at ACOG we've
been focused on
maternal mortality
and near misses for
many years recognizing
the causes for maternal death,
but also recognizing the risk
factors for maternal
morbidity, maternal death.
And let me say from the outset,
for every maternal death there
are about 60 near misses.
And those near misses include
things like hemorrhage
that didn't lead to
death, heart failure
didn't need to death,
a blood clot that
didn't lead to death,
an infection that
didn't lead to death.
And so by understanding
these type of things
it's been very,
very helpful for us.
And we've looked at this
over the course of years.
So one of the things
that I focused on
over the past couple of
years is to really push
for maternal mortality reviews,
and we spent a lot of time
on Capitol Hill, and as
Dr. Barfield has indicated
we did get legislation passed
this year called the Preventing
Maternal Death Act and
Maternal Health Accountability
Act that was signed into law.
And the idea was
that every state
would have a maternal mortality
review so we could better
understand the causes of
pregnancy related death.
There was going to be
some financial support
for the infrastructure
for states who did not
have a mature review
program, and also
for those states
who had one to try
to strengthen those program.
The other things that
we did were focus on
levels of care, which Susan
will talk a little bit more
about, recognizing
the fact that there
are things that we could do.
There were interventions
that we should have.
And I will talk a
little bit about this
later if I have time,
but access to care
is still a major issue
in the United States.
Many of us live in
rural communities
and we'll talk a little
bit about the fact
that access is a serious factor
for women to have to travel
to distances and so forth.
And the other factor, of course,
is that fragmentation of care
where the provider and
the delivery facility
are very different.
And so those also impact issues.
And with that these
are the type of things
that we've talked about this
year and we've emphasized.
We've emphasized the
challenges of access.
We've emphasized the importance
of doing the reviews.
We've emphasized
levels of care where
a person would communicate
from a rural community
to a more tertiary care center,
certain types of patients
who may be much more
appropriate to be transferred.
An example would be a lady
with a placental abnormality
with a placenta previa which
is at high risk for hemorrhage.
And even though they
may be able to do
a cesarean at that
facility, they
may not have the blood to
handle the volume of blood loss.
And so those are the kind
of challenges and things
that we focused on to
improve the quality of care
and improved outcomes
for all women.
Dr. Barfield also mentioned
the fact that as we do reviews,
we've clearly noticed
this increasing
trend over the last 20 years.
Part of that has been due
to better ascertainment,
but part of it is
also due to the fact
that women are indeed dying more
often over the last 20 years,
particularly women of color.
TINA MARTIN: Thank you.
We will definitely
delve more into that.
Susan, let's talk
to you for a second.
You're an OBGYN and
you have delivered
more than 4,000 babies.
Is that true?
SUSAN MANN: Probably 5,000.
TINA MARTIN: More
than 5,000 babies?
Oh my goodness.
All right.
And counting.
OK.
So you know firsthand what
these mothers are going through.
And you recently
published a study
co-authored by
Haywood and others
about how to make changes
quickly in hospital settings
to prevent maternal mortality.
Talk about that.
SUSAN MANN: Sure.
Thank you very much and thank
you forum for inviting me.
I have been practicing
very comfortably here
at Beth Israel in Boston
for the past 30 years.
And I've had the honor of seeing
a lot of changes over time.
Around the early 2000s
the Department of Defense
came to Beth Israel
and said we want
to work with you to
start studying teamwork
and communication
among disciplines
and see if we can impart some
of the knowledge we've gained
from the military to medicine.
And so that really became
a strong interest of mine,
and we started foundational work
that really changed how people
practice and communicate in
hospitals across the United
States and outside
the United States.
And when the increase
in maternal mortalities
continued to go up
during this period,
I was a little bit baffled
and obviously quite concerned.
I was asked by a hospital
system in South Dakota
that I was doing work
for to come out and see
if I could help them improve
their communication with some
of their rural hospitals and
critical access hospitals.
And as I mentioned, it's
a real different world
out in rural health compared to
what I'd been living in Boston.
I joke that if I sneeze
there about four people
to hand me a Kleenex.
If you're in a rural hospital
you're waiting for the truck
to come to deliver the Kleenex.
So it's quite a
different experience.
And so when I
said, well, tell me
about some of these hospitals
with a system of 17 hospitals.
They said, well, some of
them are really quite small.
And I said, how small are they?
They said, well, some of
them do 50 deliveries a year.
And I said, wow.
That's a delivery a week.
How can you be good at
doing a delivery a week?
And I said, well, obviously you
should close those hospitals.
And they said, well,
Susan, we would,
but then a woman might need to
drive six hours to have a baby.
I said you need to leave
those hospitals open
and you need to
make them better.
And she said, that's
why we called you.
So being a good researcher
I called my friend Wanda
and I said, Wanda,
where are people dying?
Are they dying in these
small rural hospitals?
Are we able to get them to
academic medical centers?
This was what?
Six, seven, eight years ago.
And she said we just don't
have great data, because
at that point in time how we
were collecting data oftentimes
would be a checkbox on
a death certificate.
We weren't always
linking it to births.
And then the address
also, you couldn't quite
tell where they were dying.
And she said, actually, Susan,
I really hate to tell you this,
but I think quite a few occur
outside of the hospital.
And so you look at opioid abuse
and domestic violence, suicide,
and all those issues.
And I said, wow.
Those are really big issues.
I'm just a practicing
obstetrician gynecologist.
I don't know that
I can tackle that,
but I certainly can
look into what is it
that we do in our hospitals?
How can we be better
prepared and how do we
get all hospitals to do this?
And so in a recent
article that I
wrote with Haywood and the
current president Lisa Allea
and Kim McKay who's my
colleague out in South Dakota,
we were really looking at how
do you introduce these concepts
to all hospitals?
And what we wanted
to focus on were
the top three preventable causes
of pregnancy related deaths.
And that includes severe
hypertension and management
even after they go home;
Postpartum hemorrhage
as we saw so many of those
women in that clip died from;
and then also
preventing blood clots.
I'm sure you heard about Serena
Williams and the troubles
that she had.
So we really wanted to
focus on what can be done,
how to improve teamwork
and communication.
And also these levels of care,
that Haywood was talking about.
If you identify somebody
that's at three C sections,
and needs to have a
fourth, should she really
be done in a hospital that
does one delivery a week?
She needs to be identified
and [? risked ?]
out to a higher level of care.
Whether she'll go there
is a different topic,
because women make their
own choices in life.
But it should be up to us
still at least educator her,
and say, we have connections.
We send our babies
out, when they're
28 weeks, to these hospitals.
We should have these kind
of connections for our moms,
as well.
TINA MARTIN: We're going
to get into all of that.
I just want to make sure that
we're connecting with Karen.
Dr. Scott are you there?
KAREN SCOTT: Yes, hi.
TINA MARTIN: You can hear us.
KAREN SCOTT: Good morning, Tina.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
KAREN SCOTT: Good
morning, panel.
TINA MARTIN: Good morning.
Good morning.
In your role at the California
Birth Equity Collaborative
and the California Maternal
Quality Care Collaborative,
you've really taken direct
aim at some of the disparities
that we've talked about.
So tell us a little
bit about your work.
KAREN SCOTT: Yes, hi.
Thank you so much.
So the California Maternal
Quality Care Collaborative,
CMQCC, is a multi-stakeholder
organization
working closely with state
and national partners
to reduce preventable causes
of maternal mortality,
maternal morbidity, and racial
disparities in California.
CMQCC uses research, QI
toolkits, statewide outreach
collaboratives, and its
innovative maternal data center
to improve health outcomes
for mothers and infants.
CMQCC was found in 2006 at
Stanford University School
of Medicine, together with
the state of California,
in response to rising maternal
mortality and morbidity rates.
Since CMQCC's
inception, California
has seen a 55% decline in
our maternal mortality,
between 2006 and
2013, at this time,
where the national
maternal mortality
rate continued to rise.
Examples of our impact
include prevention
of 120,000 early births
from 2009 to 2014,
with an increase of 8% of
births making its full term.
A reduction of maternal
morbidity by about 21%
between 2014 and '16,
among the 126 hospitals
participating in our projects
to reduce maternal hemorrhage
and preeclampsia, yet
there is more to our story.
Since 1999, the data reporting
around maternal mortality
in California show a
persistent three to four-fold
gap between black
mothers and mothers
from all other racial groups.
Maternal mortality
rates nearly doubled
for all racial ethnic groups
between, again, 1999 and 2006.
In response, the CMQCC's founded
[INAUDIBLE] 2010 [INAUDIBLE]
declined, showing a
decline in reduction
of maternal mortality.
But the expectation was
that widespread adoption
of clinical safety
bundles would reduce
this gap in the number
of maternal deaths
among black women.
However, the difference in
outcomes for black mothers,
compared with all other
racial groups, has persisted.
Further analysis revealed
that clinical safety bundles
and social support
interventions,
done in isolation, without
an integrated approach,
did not produce the
desired outcomes.
So CMQCC has now started
initiative with the California
Birth Equity Collaborative.
It really presents
an opportunity
to develop these QI toolkits
within a hospital setting,
again, to properly evaluate and
transform birth culture, care,
experiences, and outcomes
through the integration
of clinical and
sociocultural intervention
and community-hospital
partnership.
So our data show that, even in
the absence of risk factors,
such as age over 35 years,
lack of health insurance,
inadequate or no [INAUDIBLE],,
and less than a high school
education, our US
health system continues
to not be able to protect our
black mothers and [INAUDIBLE]
people from experiencing
higher numbers of deaths
and life-threatening
complications during pregnancy
and childbirth.
Again, increasing
evidence is pointing
to racism within and across
multiple levels, and not race,
as a key cause of these
birth disparities.
Again, data also show
variations in the quality
of care and outcomes between
and within [? racial groups ?]
across hospitals in California,
highlighting [INAUDIBLE]
opportunities for advancing
equity, as well as [INAUDIBLE]
racism and quality improvement.
So with our California Birth
Equity Collaborative pilot,
CMQCC aims to
transform birth culture
and care for, by, and with black
mothers and [INAUDIBLE] people
in partnership with [INAUDIBLE]
community-based organizations,
with our participating
hospitals,
with local advisor groups being
formed back into the hospitals.
As well as state and
national black women
scholars serving as
pilot mentors, who
represent various disciplines,
specifically public health
and social sciences.
TINA MARTIN: Thank
you very much.
Dr. Scott, I'm just going
to throw it back to you.
When you said racism
across all levels,
how does that translate?
How does that play out for
a mother who has given birth
or is giving birth, and
is looking for care?
How does that play out?
KAREN SCOTT: So
what we are seeing
is that what is it
about the system?
We're looking at
systems accountability.
What is it about the system
that allows variation
in the responsiveness
to a black mother who's
reporting symptoms, that are
being dismissed, discounted,
neglected?
There's a delay.
And why are we seeing
variation in the response, when
we have science technology that
shows we're able to prevent
60% of these causes?
So we're wondering, what
is it about that response
to black mothers, to
[INAUDIBLE] people
that's causing these
variations with their systems?
Where black people are
coming to the hospitals.
They're educated, they have
health insurance in California.
All of these factors that,
normally, are shown to protect
are not doing that.
So how [? we ?] look at the
ways in which interactions,
communication, the counseling,
and the decision-making
as being inclusive
of black mothers,
and their birthing support
systems, and people,
in how health care
is being delivered.
TINA MARTIN: And Susan, I
hear you listening intently.
What is your response to
what Dr. Scott's saying?
SUSAN MANN: Sure.
So about 2012, the
National Partnership
for Maternal Safety and
ACOG, and 30 organizations
came together to try
and address this issue.
And they have cranked out
about 10 bundles of care.
Recommendations for
how do you treat
hemorrhage, how do you treat
postpartum hypertension.
And about a year ago-- or
maybe this past summer--
there was an article
in the USA Today
that said hospitals know what
to do, why aren't they doing it?
And that really shook both
Dr. Haywood and I to the core.
And we said, OK, we're
putting out this material.
We're educating people.
What is the problem with
basic culture change?
And that is really
something that, I think,
needs to be looked at.
And all hospitals need
to be held accountable
for the following four things.
And it needs to be
from the C-suite
all the way down to
frontline caregivers.
If the C-suite isn't
providing training and support
for the individuals
at the bedside,
this just isn't going to happen.
And the four things
that we really looked at
were the [INAUDIBLE]
bundles, making sure
that you take what
was put out there
for maybe an academic
medical center,
but you able to apply it to
a smaller rural hospital.
So if a patient
begins to bleed, what
are the medications that are
available in a moment's notice?
And not you need some pharmacies
to release medication,
and they're not even
in the hospital.
How do you manage, if there
isn't a laboratory person
to tell you what
the blood count is?
You need to quantify
that blood loss.
And we have tools to
do it, it's just people
need to be trained on this.
Finally, a secondary is the team
training and the communication.
The obstetricians, nurse
midwives, family medicine docs,
whoever is the provider
in the community,
providing care to
these women, need
to come together with
nursing and anesthesia,
and all the hospitals
to understand
what are the demands on
the resources for that day.
And you can't go and start an
elective c-section, if somebody
else is having a hemorrhage.
The time of practicing
in individual silos
is really over.
And our care
absolutely needs to be
coordinated across the board.
And then third, we need to
take a page from the pilots.
We need to simulate
these emergencies.
You never know where things
are in your department,
until you need it.
And sometimes, oh, we
took that medicine out
of the [INAUDIBLE].
What do you mean I can't get
magnesium right at this moment,
and it's going to be
another 15 or 20 minutes?
You only find out things
like that if you try it
and practice it,
and people know what
their roles are on the team,
when these emergencies arise.
So we also recommend that
people have briefings.
We come together, as a team,
before you start a c-section,
so you understand what are
the risks for that patient.
And you give the patient a
voice in the process, as well,
to talk about what
are her concerns.
And maybe she shares
with you, my mother
had a pulmonary embolism
after she had my brother.
I forgot to mention
that to someone.
Is that important?
You're like, yes, that's
actually quite important.
Thank you.
So making sure that the patient
has a voice in this process
is very important, as well.
And then finally, what we talked
about, the levels of care,
and making sure the
patients are at least
offered to deliver
at a site that
makes the most sense for them.
Nobody wants to travel,
if they don't have to.
But boy, every week I read about
some hospital that's closing.
And I know Haywood's going
to talk about these health
deserts.
And it's just such a concern.
TINA MARTIN: And so talk
about the health deserts.
HAYWOOD BROWN: Thank you, Susan.
SUSAN MANN: [INAUDIBLE]
TINA MARTIN: Thank you, Susan.
She should be paid extra,
for doing my job for me.
HAYWOOD BROWN: We've
already alluded to the fact
that maternity care is very
fragmented in this country.
You think about whether
you're in a city like Boston,
there are actually
health deserts
here for obstetric
care, just like they
are in rural North Carolina, or
rural Florida, where I'm from.
Susan alluded to the fact
that 50% of all deliveries
occur in hospitals with three
or less deliveries a day.
50% of all counties
in the United States
do not have a practicing
OBGYN and a midwife.
So when you think
about that, you
think about the whole access
issue and availability issue.
That's a real challenge.
And so you have to
make sure that you
have ways of delivering the
same quality to individuals,
whether they're in rural
Montana or rural South Dakota,
as they are in urban Boston.
And those are
really keys to this.
And access to care and
affordability of care--
I'll talk a little bit about
funding and support for women
and having those dollars
available to go to the doctor.
Many women who, for instance,
don't have insurance,
may delay their prenatal care
until they can get on Medicaid,
or until they find the
insurance to do that.
So the financial barriers
are still there in a country
as rich as ours.
And so we really have to
focus in on this every day.
And I'll talk a little
bit more about that,
when we talk about--
but those are what we refer
to as maternity deserts.
Deserts by the aspect
of where you live,
deserts by the aspect
of not having providers,
and so forth, and so on.
And I want to just
give an example of what
Susan may be referring to.
So imagine that you are a woman
and you delivered, and you
had a near miss.
You lost a lot of blood.
You lost so much blood
that you are now weak.
And you go home with your
baby, and everything's--
imagine, though, living in an
area where you really can't get
back for your postpartum visit.
Then imagine not having
contraception available to you
for pregnancy spacing.
And so you come into
your next pregnancy.
There you are,
with a blood count
that's already half
of what it should be.
You already have another risk
factor for having a hemorrhage,
because you've had a hemorrhage.
And so when we
talk about reviews,
understanding the system issues,
where that woman could have
actually had an opportunity
to build a blood count up,
or recognizing the fact that,
if she has another hemorrhage,
she could lose all
her blood volume,
and be at risk for mortality.
So those are the type of things,
that Wanda will share with you,
that we learned from reviews.
And that's really key to
understanding what those risk
factors might be
for that woman who
is in a vulnerable situation.
TINA MARTIN: So Wanda,
let's talk about that.
This data collection,
how important is it?
WANDA BARFIELD: So maternal
mortality review committees
are really our opportunity
to truly understand
what is going on around the
circumstance of a woman's
death.
I sort of think of,
in infectious disease,
we talk about how we're
going to investigate
sources of infection.
But for maternal mortality, I
think of it more like a CSI.
There's a case that
needs to be reviewed,
and we really need to understand
the underlying causes related
to that death.
And it requires a
multidisciplinary team
that's not just clinical,
but also the issues related
to social factors, as well,
that are very important.
Like why wasn't it a
woman able to come back?
There are social
circumstances, whether it's
issues of transportation
or family circumstances
that may not allow that.
We need to better
understand other factors,
such as mental health,
and how that might also
contribute to a woman's death.
So these review
committees really
have an opportunity to really
not only uncover those causes--
these are things that we cannot
get out of a death certificate.
Yet there is also an opportunity
for the review committees
to then think about ways
to prevent future deaths.
And this is a really
important aspect.
And in combination with the
recommendations that they
can make to facilities,
whether it's safety bundles,
or in larger areas
like California--
which has really led
the way, in terms
of thinking about perinatal
quality collaboratives--
there are so many states now
that are working together
to try to think about
these systematic issues,
and ways that they
can improve health.
So I think this is a
really important issue.
And back to what Karen
was saying about some
of the challenges, with
regard to disparities,
I think we need to understand
that there are systems
in place, or not in
place, that really affect
the aspects of women's health.
We know that there
are facilities
that African-American
women may go to,
that have a lower quality
of care, systematically.
And we really have
an opportunity
to try to think about how we
can improve that access to care,
as well as the quality of care.
And it's not just having those
particular interventions,
but what are those
process measures that
make those interventions
happen in a rapid manner,
and an appropriate
manner every time?
TINA MARTIN: And Ana,
you were saying something
before we came in here about,
from your global perspective,
the experience of care.
ANA LANGER: Yeah.
TINA MARTIN: Talk a
little bit about that.
ANA LANGER: Thank you.
Thank you for that question.
In fact, you asked the question
about how racism plays out.
And one of the ways
I think it plays out
is through disrespectful
and abusive treatment
during maybe pregnancy, but most
importantly, during childbirth.
And this is an area
that we, globally,
have been studying
quite extensively.
In fact, we've documented
that everywhere--
it could happen to any
woman, but it mostly
happens to women who are
vulnerable because of race,
ethnicity, age,
socioeconomic status--
women are very poorly treated.
In fact, they are subjected
to completely unacceptable
behaviors.
Sometimes they are slapped, they
are spoken to in a very rude
way, they are retained
in facilities--
sometimes because
they cannot pay.
Well, obviously, their informed
consent is not asked for.
So there are so many ways
women are poorly treated.
And that's the
experience of care.
So we've been talking mostly
about clinical care, which
is obviously essential.
But the way women experience
their childbirth is also
critical.
If their symptoms
are dismissed--
as some of my colleagues
here were saying-- obviously,
there are immediate
consequences.
But even when that's
not the situation, when
women are poorly
treated, they will
mistrust the medical
system, the health system.
And they may not come back,
when they have another pregnancy
and when they have
a complication.
And probably they will spread
the word in their communities
that that's a facility or
a place where you are not
treated as you deserve.
So globally, we've
measured the prevalence
of disrespect and abuse,
and it's very common.
We've also identified
some of the reasons
behind it, particularly
among the health workforce.
Obviously, most people
in the health workforce
are well-intentioned.
They studied, and they
practice their careers,
because they want
to help others.
But sometimes, they are
disrespected themselves.
They work in very
poor conditions
that don't allow them to provide
the care a woman deserve.
Of course, disrespect
and abuse is
unacceptable under any
circumstance, but still.
And we've also tested
some interventions
that I think would be
helpful here in the US,
to address some of those issues.
TINA MARTIN: Like--
ANA LANGER: For instance, a
way to increase accountability.
Facilities need to be
prepared to answer questions
from their users about why
some things that are happening.
Women need to be informed
about what's going to happen,
when they go to the
facility for delivery.
Very often, women come
from other places, never
have been in that place,
and they have no idea
what's going to happen to them.
And that's very, very stressful.
Sometimes women with a lower
level of education, and maybe
with some language
barriers, will not
understand what's
going on in the labrum.
So having someone with
them, a companion--
either a companion like a
doula or maybe a relative--
will make the
experience stressful,
and will it provide a
link between the woman
and the health care providers.
So all those
interventions have been
tested, in terms of
their effectiveness,
their feasibility,
and acceptability.
They will probably
have to be adopted,
those that are new here.
But I think they are all good
ideas, that we already know
work, at least to some extent.
TINA MARTIN: And Karen, I
see you nodding your head,
when you were listening
to what Ana was saying.
What do you think
about the ideas
that she just mentioned,
in terms of care?
KAREN SCOTT: So I agree.
I think there's a lot that is
happening in the International
space, around respectful
and dignified care,
that our nation is struggling
with that language.
So in order to
transform culture,
it must happen with language.
So how do we acknowledge
what nations around
the [INAUDIBLE] world around
really holding to the fact
that we're experiencing
obstetric mistreatment
or [? obstetric ?] violence.
And those are words that
our systems, I would say,
are afraid to call
out and to really
speak very truthfully, in a very
transparent and meaningful way,
to our communities
who are experiencing
forms of structural violence.
And the ways in which their
bodies are [INAUDIBLE] value
really--
approaching black [? birthing ?]
people in a deficit model,
in a mother [? framed ?] or
[? individual framed ?] way.
So how do we
acknowledge and amplify
a community-informed
knowledge base
of respectful and
dignified care?
And how, with [? a ?]
shared language and meaning,
then really create the
spaces for black mothers
[? and birthing ?] people
to help us define what
a patient-reported metric of
respect and dignity would look
like in the hospital setting,
so that we could build trusting
relationships?
So that could really have active
and reflective and responsive
listening, so that we
could also have really
patient-centered
connections and counseling,
that's not just based
on risk stratification.
What if we were to do
asset amplification?
We continue to
pathologize birth, yet
it can be difficult
and dangerous,
but if that's the narrative
that we are perpetuating,
how can people feel
dignified while giving birth?
And when birth can be a
ritualistic or traditional rite
of passage for some
of our communities.
What we're doing,
as I'm speaking of,
is having this patient-reported
experience-- not outcome,
but experience metric.
It can allow us to build
systems, accountability
structures of processes
and mechanisms that really
stellar black women,
black working people,
and, again, how care
can be delivered
to them that honors them.
What it looked like if
the outcome-- not just
is decreasing death,
or complications--
but what if the outcome
is the experience?
And so we're able
to really transform
the culture within
a hospital setting.
Lest we think about
the experience
that someone is having,
that despite having
a difficult birth or
an unexpected outcome,
that the experience is
still being dignified.
Having some sense of autonomy
in their birthing options.
That can really shift
the ways in which people
in our country experience
birth, particularly
people sitting at
the margins, I'm
like black mothers and
black working people,
and their support
partners and families.
TINA MARTIN: you very much.
We're going to go
to one more theme,
and then we're going
to take some questions,
because we have many people
who have many questions.
All right.
This theme, managing the
risks of chronic disease,
including heart
disease, pregnancy
in the postpartum period.
Susan, I'll shoot
that out to you first.
SUSAN MANN: Sure.
So we talked a little
bit about risks.
Identification is
very important.
One of the other things, that
Haywood and I have published
on, is a potential
use of telehealth
for patients that have some
chronic diseases, for diabetes.
So that these women don't
have to travel hours
to more academic
medical centers.
Can't that data be transmitted?
Can't patients have
face-to-face telehealth visits?
So looking at what is it that we
can do to identify these health
risks, and then to make it
more patient-friendly and
user-friendly, and
this difficult time.
TINA MARTIN: Haywood?
HAYWOOD BROWN: Yeah.
I think we also have to remind
ourselves that about 60%
of all maternal deaths
occur postpartum.
And about a decade
ago, I really changed
the whole structural
postpartum follow-up.
And it was my theme during my
presidency where we actually
started seeing women a lot
earlier in their postpartum
care.
For instance, patients who
really had major complications
being seen in two weeks.
The idea is to screen them
for postpartum depression.
If the patient has had
a major complications,
really counsel them, again,
about recurrence risks,
and things like that.
But we also know that, by doing
earlier postpartum visits,
you decrease the rate of
readmissions and death,
particularly for things
like blood clots, which
are more likely to occur
in the postpartum period.
Heart failure, which is
most likely to present.
And keep in mind that now,
cardiovascular disease
is one of the leading causes
for maternal mortality.
And many of these
women were present late
in the pregnancy,
or early postpartum.
And so change in those
paradigms and getting people
to think about that has been
extremely, extremely important.
We know if you deliver from a
rural community, your chance
of readmission or
complications and mortality
are a lot higher
than if you delivered
in an urban community.
So those are the type of things.
And we're focus more on policies
that would actually cover
at least 12 weeks postpartum.
And that's the work that we're
doing with Medicaid right now,
to focus in on that.
But earlier follow-up,
follow and guidelines--
particularly for hypertension--
looking for heart failure,
and all those type of things
are very, very important.
TINA MARTIN: And And,
before we get to questions,
community partnerships.
Did you want to talk
about that a little bit?
ANA LANGER: Yes,
I would love to.
In fact, in public health,
and in medicine too,
we work too much in silos.
And we need to break
those artificial silos,
and in the case
of women's health,
we need to take a
life course approach.
In fact, what happens to a woman
during pregnancy, delivery,
and the six weeks postpartum--
or even 12 weeks postpartum--
is a result of what has
happened to those women earlier.
Maybe starting in
adolescence, or maybe
even when they were children.
And the consequences
of what happens
during the maternal
health period
will happen, or will be evident
and visible later in life,
as well.
We know how much the
risk of type 2 diabetes
increases among women who
had gestational diabetes,
or a hypertension among
women who had pre-eclampsia.
So we need to take
that approach.
And in fact, I wanted
to quickly mention
that we are now
starting a project here,
in our own backyard, in Boston,
in collaboration with Ariadne
Labs, and with the generous
support of the Boston
Foundation, to look at racial
and ethnic disparities--
but also immigration status
disparities-- among women
during maternal health
care and one year later.
Because we want to look at that
interface between what happens
during the traditional
maternal health period,
and a what happens after
women have delivered.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
All right.
Rafael Baez has a question.
I'm going to allow anyone--
including you, Karen-- to
answer these questions,
if you feel so inclined.
All right.
Rafael has a two-part question.
The first part is how can local
government and state government
help reduce maternal mortality?
WANDA BARFIELD: So I
think one major step
is through maternal
mortality review committees.
HAYWOOD BROWN: Absolutely.
WANDA BARFIELD: And I
think that the time is now,
in terms of that opportunity.
So working with both clinical
care and public health,
state health officials, leaders
of Schools of Public Health,
leaders in state-based ACOG.
We have a real opportunity
to really work together,
in terms of trying to reduce
the risk of maternal death.
HAYWOOD BROWN: I
could add to that
by saying that
every state, almost,
has a perinatal collaborative
that are working with our State
Department of Health.
And one of the ways that
you get reviews going
is through your legislature, and
to your Department of Health.
And it really is a partnership.
Getting that partnership
going, you really
want not government
interference,
but government help,
in order to make sure
that they support these
initiatives that you're doing.
And I think that's the key.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
All right.
Curtis [? Older-- ?]
oh, I'm sorry, Karen.
Did you want to say something?
KAREN SCOTT: I do, I do.
I want to add to
that, because I'm
thinking about local
or state government.
I would say infrastructure.
Like funding the unsung
heroes, the unusual
suspects in black
maternal health
equity, which are out lactation
consultants and our doulas.
And so they are cultural
brokers between hospitals
and communities that usually
go unnoticed, and not valued.
And so that is
what we are doing,
is really strengthening
those cultural brokers
of bridges, who already have
the trust and the respect
of our communities.
But they also sit in those
spaces within the hospital,
navigating these hierarchical
power differentials,
and doing that as an advocate
on behalf of our communities.
So I really think
we need to reinvest
in lactation consultants and
doulas who are really sitting
in those spaces, that
can bridge hospitals
and communities to move towards
black maternal and health
equity.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
Thank you.
OK.
Curtis [? Older. ?] I'm trying
to get as many questions
as I can in here.
Has anyone done a
study on the death rate
for pregnancy and
childbirth for married women
versus unmarried women?
And if so, what do
those stats indicate?
HAYWOOD BROWN: I think those are
the things we find in reviews.
And it's no question
that unmarried women,
unplanned pregnancies
have higher risk
for not only morbidity,
but potentially mortality.
And I think those are the
things that we've learned.
The other thing that
we have appreciated now
is that we have pregnancies
in women who are older.
And we recognize,
just from the data,
that pregnancies in women
who are in their late 40s
have a higher risk for
morbidity and mortality,
even though the woman may
appear to be quite healthy.
In one study, it was shown
that maybe as many as 20%
of women who have
pregnancies over age 45,
particularly if they have twins,
have a cardiovascular event.
And so when we think about the
rise in cardiovascular disease
as a cause of maternal
death, it really
plays into the role
of how important
preconception counsel, if you
have an underlying condition,
or if you have certain
types of things.
So yes, that data is there.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
Anybody else want to comment?
WANDA BARFIELD: Marital
status and education
may be a proxy for
wealth and income.
And we know still that
African-American women who
are well-educated still
have a higher risk of death
than low-educated white women.
HAYWOOD BROWN: And the
thing Wanda's saying,
I've mentioned the
whole story of anemia.
Poor women and women of color
are more likely to be anemic.
And so anemia is a risk factor
for postpartum hemorrhage.
But also, if you lose blood, you
are more likely a risk factor
for higher morbidity
and mortality.
So irrespective
of socioeconomic,
sometimes, anemia can be a
factor that's easily corrected
with just some iron pills.
TINA MARTIN: Thank you.
Karen, I hear your
microphone on.
KAREN SCOTT: Yes.
I just want to continue
to add, because I always
want to critically challenge
these tropes and narratives
around the contributors
[? and ?] drivers
of severe maternal morbidity.
Because even with the
data that we found,
that even after controlling for
age, BMI, or obesity, as well
as comorbidities, those are
not the largest contributors
to severe maternal morbidity.
So again, it's pointing
back to not the individual
or the black body,
but what is happening
when that black body shows
up within the hospital
setting that's impacting
their responsiveness.
We have these tools,
we have these policies,
we have these protocols.
But why are we not responding
to a particular group
in an effective, appropriate,
timely manner, as we
do with other populations?
TINA MARTIN: Thank you.
And time is leaving us here.
We're done at 1 o'clock.
I just want to give
each of the speakers
an opportunity to give us maybe
one or two takeaways from this.
Wanda, we'll start with you.
WANDA BARFIELD: So I think that
there is a lot that we can do,
but one area that's
really critical for states
is to think about insuring
risk-appropriate care.
We need to standardize
and improve care
to ensure that all
women are delivering
at the right place,
and the right time,
and the right hospital.
TINA MARTIN: Ana.
ANA LANGER: Yes.
I would like to emphasize that
the US is part of the globe.
And that we should break
that silo, too, and think
about maternal health
for all women everywhere,
women's health, if we
want to be more inclusive.
And so that's one key message
that I would like to a to share
with you.
And another one, that comes
from low and middle income
countries, is that
many of those countries
have made maternal health
care free and available
for all women.
And those countries are
much poorer than the US.
So I think it's quite
appalling to think
that so many women still face
financial barriers to have
access to quality care
in a timely fashion.
So what can I say?
I would encourage us all to
push so all women in the US
have free access to
maternal health care.
TINA MARTIN: Thank you.
Haywood.
HAYWOOD BROWN: We
have to re-educate
on the importance of
the postpartum visit,
and postpartum follow-up,
and early postpartum
follow-up for all
women, irrespective
of where they live.
We know that women
who are poor are
less likely to show up for
their postpartum visit,
mainly because of barriers.
And we need to make sure
that that's emphasized,
at the time of discharge
from the hospital,
that the patient
understands the [INAUDIBLE],,
providers understand
the importance of it,
and systems understand the
importance of that visit.
And we need to be
able to have coverage
for women for an extended
postpartum period.
It's not a one episode visit.
It really is seeing the patient,
when she needs to be seen.
TINA MARTIN: Susan.
SUSAN MANN: It's
always hard to go last.
Everyone's been some fabulous
[? points ahead of you. ?]
TINA MARTIN: No,
you're not last.
Karen's last.
SUSAN MANN: Oh, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I forgot about you, Karen.
I apologize.
You'll have a hard
time, I promise.
However, I think really this
maternal mortality thing
is so multifactorial.
And hospitals really
need to be held
accountable for their
state of preparedness,
and their ability to respond
to emergencies, as they arise.
Regardless of who the patient
is, what color she is,
where she gives birth.
It needs to be,
across the board,
a level of accountability,
like I said, from the C-suite
all the way down to the
front line caregivers.
TINA MARTIN: Karen,
final thoughts?
KAREN SCOTT: Two.
So I really want to advocate and
hold, again, as we're saying,
systems accountable for--
I'm going to say-- the
cultural rigor, and humility
and responsiveness, and
the scientific integrity
and validity of our work.
And also to dismantle the silos.
To invest in public
health and social sciences
as transdisciplinary
approaches that really censor
and uplift the
voices and knowledge
and expertise of
our black mothers
and [? birthing ?] people.
TINA MARTIN: Excellent.
Thank you very much.
That was easy to close out.
All right.
I'm Tina Martin.
I would encourage you to join
us for the next forum, Feeding
10 Billion by 2050, Creating
Sustainable and Healthy Food
Culture.
That is March 22nd,
2019, noon to 1:00.
Thank you so much everyone
in our audience and everyone
at home for joining us.
We appreciate it.
Take care.
[APPLAUSE]